people sometimes
ask me you know you go up and under
communism
you know was there anything good about
communism
and it's difficult for me to talk about
it because it's not uh communism is one
of those things that's looked down on
like without in absolutist terms
currently
but you could still in my perspective
talk about the actual forget communism
or whatever the actual
term is but you know certain
ways that the society function that we
can learn lessons from and one of the
things
in the soviet union that was highly
prized
is knowledge not even now it's wisdom
and the skill of invention
of innovation at a young age
so we're not talking about a selection
process where you pick the best students
in the school to do the mathematics
or to read literature it's like
everybody did it
everybody it was almost treated as if
anyone could be the next einstein
anybody could be
the next i don't know hemingway james
joyce
and so you're forcing an education on
the populace
and a rigorous deep education like
as opposed to kind of like oh we want to
make sure we um
teach to the weaker student in the class
which american systems can sometimes do
because we don't want to leave anyone
behind
the the russian system was
anyone can be the strongest student and
we're going to teach you the strongest
student
and we're going to just to pretend or
force
everybody even the weakest student to be
strong and what that results in
it's obviously this is what people talk
about is a huge amount of pressure
like it's psychologically very difficult
this is why people struggle when they go
to mit
this very competitive environment it can
be very psychologically difficult but at
the same time
it's bringing out the best out of people
and
that mathematics was certainly one of
those things and
exactly what you're saying which kind of
clicked with me just now as opposed to
kind of a
spelling bee in the united states
which i guess you spell i'm horrible at
this but it's a competition about
spelling which
i'm not sure but you could argue doesn't
generalize well to future skills
mathematics especially this kind of
mathematics
is essentially formalized competition of
invention
of uh of creating
new ideas and that generalizes really
really well so
that's that's quite brilliantly put i
didn't really think about that so this
is not just about the competition this
is about
developing minds that uh will come
come to do some incredible stuff in the
future
yeah actually i want to respond to a
couple of things there the first one is
one
um which is this notion of whether or
not that is possible in a
non-authoritarian regime
i think it is and that's actually why i
spent some of my efforts
before the kovit thing uh actually
trying to work towards there
the reason is because if you think about
it let's say in america
lots of people are pretty serious about
training very hard for football
or if baseball or basketball basketball
is very very accessible but lots of
people are doing that
why well actually i think that what this
what what
what was going on with the authoritarian
thing was at least
the message that was universally sent
was being
a good thinker and a creator of ideas
is a good thing yes exactly
there's no reason why that message can't
be sent that's right everywhere
and i think it actually should be
you